let me just bring you some breaking news
coming into us from the Royal College of
Nursing who have announced the last few
moments at new strike dates for January
in England they've said that thousands
of nurses will go on strike in England
again on January the 18th and 19th they
also say that further dates will be
confirmed in the New Year we have a call
seen two days of walkouts by nurses this
month on the 15th and early this week on
the 20th in a dispute over pay and we
were expecting more dates to be
announced because the union the RCN had
given the health secretary Steve Barkley
until last night until Thursday night to
say that he was prepared to reopen
negotiations over pay or it would
escalate strikes this month and because
there was no sign that that had happened
these new dates were indeed expected so
those new dates announced by the Royal
College of Nursing are in England are
for January the 8 18th and 19th but they
say that further dates will be confirmed
in the new year so we'll keep an eye on
that plenty of a reaction to come no
doubt the Prime Minister just an hour or
so ago was asked about his reaction to
strikes across a range of Industries and
he said that he was very sad and
disappointed about disruption to
people's lives